chicken and chicory and Masala sauce  season the chicken breasts  add to hot olive oil skin side down lay  away from you to stop it all splashing  slice chicory this versatile vegetable  can be read all white has a lovely  bitter taste and is great cooked all raw  crush a clove of garlic and add then  sprigs of thyme when the chicken skin is  crisp turn over along with a chicory  for the sauce add Masala a sweet  fortified wine from Sicily  than 150 ml of chicken stock  to make the sauce Wonder too rich and  glossy add butter and simmer for 10  minutes  plate up and spoon over the sauce  cooked in under 20 minutes chicken and  chicory in Masala sauce  [Music]